the Joe Rogan experience yeah you see
the Gillette razor commercial where they
is it the Gillette one where the two
firemen kiss I don't think I don't cross
yeah who are you going for like you
think gay guys are do you know what we
want to fight fires now but it was like
I get it you're progressive it's like
this god dammit know what the commercial
expensive though isn't it like dude if
you buy into that like like oh my god
I'm so happy this company is is Woking
you're just a market they're just taking
advantage of you did you try to make
money off of you sort of but it's also
hot there's like hot fireman and and
they're making out and they you know the
guy comes back from a fire and he's
ready to get some dick right now holla
it looks fun he's a hero
as long as my lesbians so they're trying
to sell you insurance or whatever the
[ __ ] they're so who did the commercial
but I remember saying okay we're being
progressive I love it why not I don't
give a [ __ ] go for it I just find it
weird I find it strange the woke
capitalism thing that people that
companies will take a position that you
think would turn off like 50% of the
people who buy from them but do they do
it to prove their there I don't know
goodness yeah but it doesn't hurt does
it hurt like does anybody go [ __ ] blue
cross I'm getting my [ __ ] insurance
from that people are lasers brought
whatever the cheapest option is they're
buying that it's like the equalized
thing that just happened nobody's
[ __ ] leaving Equinox let me tell you
something there's no other option it's
convenient you got your [ __ ] gym
membership a handful of people or virtue
signaling but all the people complaining
saying boycott Equinox online
they're not [ __ ] Equinox members and
their [ __ ] owner one of the owners
was a trump supporter he gave money
that's right
he held a fundraiser last week for Trump
so people were freaking out saying to
boycott the brand but it's like where
else you're gonna go there's not another
high-end gym that's all over the place
like no praise are near the exact same
political beliefs it's like if I go if I
go to buy a sandwich do I have to go
like so where were you on the
Iraq war no okay let me say you know
it's a company that preys on your
laziness is the insurance that you get
through like sag-aftra
mm-hmm they like it's that you know you
get it for free if you qualify and then
when you don't qualify for it you're
still enrolled in it and it's like the
most expensive insurance does that make
sense you know I mean like and they kind
of pray and that kind of got me almost
in that way where a year where I it
wasn't taking care of I was like oh I
don't want to switch out and then have
any doctor sent you know I mean like be
to be different so they they kind of get
you like that do this Trump thing is
that give if you support anything that
he does even in just as business
practices then you're racist like
everything that you support if he
supports it you're racist yeah it's
crazy
you're not see you're racist and when
somebody calls you're racist or Nazi and
even people that don't believe that they
don't want to stand with you and defend
you because then they're being perceived
as defending or racist or Nazi and it's
a trick and it's very effective juicy so
popper I don't know why this guy
supports Trump but maybe he could
explain it right and he's a real estate
guy he's a big real estate guy related
properties he is nothing to this Jim
okay this has to do with the fact that
he probably has real estate deals that
for a very very long time with Trump and
his gym is inconsequential compared to
the billion-dollar company that he runs
well that makes sense then that makes
sense why he would support Trump
especially if he knows Trump but it's uh
if you you can't see that I mean if you
have a problem with that and many people
would right
many people would have a problem with
that like that's a different thing but
if you if you if you hear what people
are saying they're saying if you support
Trump that you support races so you
support white nationalist you put and I
think you're leaving so many people out
of the conversation when you do that oh
yeah I mean the guy got was sixty-two
million people to vote for him so if
you're saying anyone who supports him is
some type of Nazi white nationalist then
we got bigger problems break up nobody
knows a definition of those things
anymore when Miley you said about Marlo
when he came on the things he was called
that just like yeah on paper couldn't
even apply to be right would never be
accepted into being a Nazi or white
surprised you guys remember when we were
kids we read about McCarthyism know
the Red Scare we only always thought
like God we're past that
that kind of shits never gonna happen
again but what that is is like a symptom
of people worried about people defecting
from their tribe or turning on their
tribe and we we have this like built-in
fear of this kind of [ __ ] happening well
there's that aspect to it right it's the
people who are worried about people
defecting and then you have the
opportunists who can play off that and
go instead of having a win an argument
or having to you know like convince
people I'm just gonna say you're with
the other tribe you're in this bad group
so you're don't even talk to that person
yeah I don't even listen to what they
have to say and if you're in tribal on
every issue you're a [ __ ] dolt I was
gonna say why do you have to be so
defined by your Chi well you know I mean
like I would love to hear the argument
about the the but what it does good for
him for his real estate ventures I would
love to hear it like an honestly laid
out argument of why someone like Trump's
better if you're a real estate developer
and it might be a significant part of
his business yeah not being an apologize
any my people all people also will just
like there's this weird thing where
people think that business owners and
people that make a lot of money are
inherently bad but it's like I don't
know just cuz somebody is really good
and really successful he's got kids he
wants to feed he has grandkids he wants
to watch grow up and go to college it's
like I don't know I don't think this is
necessarily just bad people that have a
lot of money I think that there's a lot
of good people that have a lot of money
as well and I think they do a lot of
good [ __ ] why just you know whenever
someone gets really upset about an issue
you always have to wonder like how much
of it going in there was I mean what
what is upsetting to you is upsetting to
you that anyone who supports Trump the
Trump represents all the things that are
wrong with America today in terms like
white nationalists and terrorist attacks
mass shootings and and and and and
misogyny yeah massage they keeping the
immigrants out of being mean and be in
America first like [ __ ] it's uh it's one
of those things today where if you if
you support any part of that any part of
even if it's good for your business
you're just magnet for [ __ ] people
are angry at all the things though that
whole list was like chick-fil-a
McDonald's like yeah yeah
businesses numbers crazy electricity a
lot of big businesses support Trump but
it's isn't it so weird how people like
project their own thing onto the
situation because even like that you
just said like what everyone hates about
Trump but the people who support Trump
they're not even on the other side of
those issues it's not like they're like
no we are pro white nationalists they
just see him as a completely different
thing
they're like making the country great
and jobs and draining the swamp and all
these other things like they have people
are looking at the same thing and seeing
very different realities yeah
yeah they are and people are going in
with their preconceived bias and getting
them confirmed you know with everything
even with the way you looked at the
Mueller report like the Republicans
looked at as a victory and the Democrats
looked at as some sort of like an open
door to impeachment yeah but that was I
don't know this [ __ ] if the thing
starts off with every day you're hearing
on the news that the president is
colluding with a hostile foreign power
he's a Russian puppet he's working with
Vladimir Putin
and then by the end you're like we have
to impeach him because he thought about
obstructing the investigation that he
was declared not guilty and it's like
this is getting weird you guys were
gonna be upset no matter what you found
100 percent left Trump it's daytime
trying to say sounds like he does Trump
I'm going hard not see this time I'm not
coming back on the show I'm going hard
this time it's the fucked-up part is
only having really two choices like
we're scrambling to see whose choice
number two who's gonna be the one that
opposes Trump and you've seen people
starting to crack under pressure like
re-entry pressure whoa they try to
figure out who's gonna be Ben Gleib
maybe imagine imagine we all get doubted
them gets through them becomes president
will be [ __ ]